This episode is brought to you by Accenture. When your advertising operations fall out of sync, everything else follows. Spotify and Accenture are working together to reinvent the rhythm of ad sales, using automation, analytics, and smarter workflows to simplify campaign delivery and access better data across the business. The result? Less time spent on operations, more time connecting brands with the moments and fandoms that matter most. Learn more at Accenture.com slash Spotify.
本期节目由埃森哲赞助。当您的广告运营脱节时，其他一切也会随之脱节。Spotify与埃森哲正在合作重塑广告销售的节奏，利用自动化、分析和更智能的工作流程来简化广告系列交付，并获取整个企业的更好数据。结果如何？减少花在运营上的时间，腾出更多时间将品牌与至关重要的时刻和粉丝群体连接起来。请访问 Accenture.com/Spotify 了解更多信息。
Speaking of psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning some of our favorite episodes from the past. In 2024, I talked to psychologist Daniel Wan about sports fandom, what drives sports super fans, why are some people fair weather fans while others love to root for the underdog, and whether a crowd of supportive fans can affect the outcome of a game. I hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. We'll be back with new episodes beginning August 26th. This year, more than 120 million Americans watched the Super Bowl on television, the biggest single-network telecast audience in history.
Speaking of Psychology 栏目目前正在进行暑期休息，因此我们将重播过去的一些最爱单集。在 2024 年，我与心理学家丹尼尔·万（Daniel Wan）探讨了体育粉丝文化、是什么驱动着超级体育粉丝、为什么有些人是顺风顺水才支持的“顺风迷”，而另一些人则热爱支持弱势的一方，以及支持性的观众人群是否能影响比赛结果。希望您喜欢这期来自档案库的节目。我们将在 8 月 26 日开始恢复播出新节目。今年，超过 1.2 mil 美元...不对，超过 1.2 亿美国人在电视上观看了超级碗，这是历史上单一电视网转播观众人数最多的一次。
Okay, some of those viewers might have tuned in to see Taylor Swift, but a lot of them were there for the football. Almost 40% of Americans say that they follow sports somewhat or very closely, according to a 2023 Pew Research Center poll. And about 7% of them are super fans who follow. sports extremely closely and talk about sports every day. You might know some of those super fans or maybe you're one yourself. So whether it's college sports, the NFL, the WNBA, or Major League Baseball, what drives sports fans to become so passionately attached to their
好吧，其中一些观众可能是为了看泰勒·斯威夫特而收看的，但他们中的很多人都是为了橄榄球而来的。根据皮尤研究中心 2023 年的一项民意调查，近 40% 的美国人表示他们或多或少或非常密切地关注体育赛事。其中约 7% 是超级粉丝，他们关注体育...极其密切，并且每天都在谈论体育。你可能认识其中一些超级粉丝，或者你自己就是其中之一。因此，无论是大学体育、NFL、WNBA 还是美国职业棒球大联盟，究竟是什么驱使体育粉丝对他们的...
teams? Is being a fan good for your mental health, even when your team is losing? Why are some people fair weather fans while others love to root for the underdog? What about aggression among sports fans? Why do some fans behave badly? Can playing in front of a big supportive crowd of fans actually affect a team's performance? In other words, is there really a home field advantage? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
球队产生如此热烈的情感？成为一名粉丝对你的心理健康有好处吗，即使你的球队正在输球？为什么有些人是顺风迷，而另一些人却喜欢支持弱势的一方？体育粉丝之间的攻击性是怎么回事？为什么有些粉丝表现得很糟糕？在大量支持性粉丝面前比赛真的会影响球队的表现吗？换句话说，真的存在主场优势吗？欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is a guest today is. Dr. Dan Wan, a distinguished professor in the Department of Psychology at Murray State University in Murray, Kentucky. He's been studying the psychology of sports fans and spectators since the mid-1980s with a particular interest in fans' psychological connection to their teams. He's the author of more than 200 journal articles and multiple books, including sport fans, the psychology and social impact of fandom. His work has been covered by major media outlets, including ESPN, Time magazine, The Washington Post, the New York Times, and Sports Illustrated.
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是...我今天的嘉宾是...来自肯塔基州默里市默里州立大学心理学系的杰出教授丹·万（Dan Wan）博士。自 20 世纪 80 年代中期以来，他一直致力于研究体育迷和观众的心理学，对粉丝与球队之间的心理联系有着特别的兴趣。他是 200 多篇期刊文章和多本书的作者，其中包括《体育迷：粉丝文化的心理学与社会影响》。他的工作受到了各大媒体的报道，包括 ESPN、《时代》杂志、《华盛顿邮报》、《纽约时报》和《体育画报》。
Dr. Juan is a research fellow in the Sport Marketing Association and has won many awards for his research and teaching. Dr. Juan, thank you for joining me today. Absolutely. My pleasure to be here. So let's start with the big question. Why do people become sports fans? What drives their intense attachment to a sport or a particular team or even an individual player? Yeah, that's so oftentimes the $2 million question, right? And anytime you have a $2 million question, you can end up with about two million different answers. So I think that given the time constraints that we might have, I actually teach an entire
万博士是体育营销协会的研究员，并因其研究和教学赢得了许多奖项。万博士，谢谢你今天能来。绝对的。很高兴能来到这里。那么，让我们从一个宏大的问题开始。为什么人们会成为体育粉丝？是什么驱使他们对一项运动、某支特定球队甚至某个球员产生如此强烈的依恋？是的，这通常是一个价值两百万美元的问题，对吧？每当你有一个价值两百万美元的问题时，你最终可能会得到大约两00万个不同的答案。所以我想，鉴于我们可能有的时间限制，我实际上教授了一门关于...
course on the sport fan psychology that we, you know, spend four months talking about this. But I think that a pretty straightforward answer would be to say that one thing that we know that sport phantom does is it really does help individuals meet basic psychological needs. That sure, you can say that, okay, so-and-so follow sport because well it's fun or because maybe it provides an escape from the stress of life or the boredom of their life or, you know, maybe in some way they enjoy the aesthetics of it, the beauty and the grace and the artistic nature that come with some sport events. But really what we've learned in the past about decade is we've sort of undersold ourselves in
体育迷心理学的整门课程，我们花了四个月的时间来讨论这个。但我认为，一个非常直接的回答是，我们所知道的一件事是，体育粉丝文化确实有助于个体满足基本的心理需求。当然，你可以说，好吧，某某人关注体育是因为它很有趣，或者因为它可能提供了一种逃避生活压力或生活无聊的方式，或者，你知道，也许在某种程度上他们欣赏它的美学、美感以及伴随某些体育赛事的艺术性质。但实际上我们在过去大约十年中所了解到的是，我们在...
terms of the psychology of sport fandom. And it really does mean more than what we had previously thought. Some examples that I can come up with pretty quickly here would be, for example, by being a fan of a particular team or a sport or even a player, it gives that individual the opportunity to feel a sense of belongingness. We are very social creatures. Affiliation is certainly, you know, born in us through evolution. And one thing that fandom allows people to do is to get and impart these groups. I mean, if you reside in a local community and you follow the local team, it's hard to feel lonely.
体育粉丝心理学方面有点低估了自己。它确实比我们之前想象的更有意义。我在这里可以很快想到的几个例子，比如，通过成为某支特定球队、某项运动甚至某个球员的粉丝，它给了这个人一种归属感。我们是非常具有社会属性的生物。归属感无疑是，你知道的，通过进化生来就有的。粉丝文化允许人们做的一件事就是融入并参与这些群体。我的意思是，如果你居住在一个当地社区并关注当地球队，你就很难感到孤独。
It's hard to feel isolated, right? And it gives you this critical link to others. But the flip side is also that we don't want to be cookie cutters. We don't want to be exact because of everybody else. We like to stand out in some way, be unique in some way. And sport fandom also provides that. So it gives us this power to be distinct and unique. It's funny that when I talk to sports fans and given what I do,
你很难感到孤立，对吧？它为你提供了与他人建立这种关键联系的途径。但硬币的另一面也是，我们不想成为流水线上的饼干模具。我们不想和其他所有人一模一样。我们喜欢在某种程度上脱颖而出，在某种程度上保持独一无二。体育粉丝文化也提供了这一点。所以它赋予了我们这种与众不同和独一无二的力量。有趣的是，当我与体育粉丝交谈时，考虑到我的工作，
do. I do that quite frequently. I'll ask him, so who are your favorite teams? And let's say I'm talking to somebody who resides near Boston. They'll say, well, I love the Red Sox and I love the Celtics and I love the Patriots and I love Manchester United. You're like, wait, what? One of these things is not like the other. And it's so interesting because that one team allows them to just feel different from everybody else. So I would say that the most straightforward answer is that people are fans because it helps them meet these basic psychological needs. It's not the only way that they can meet these needs, but things like belongingness and the need for the distinction and the need for structure and the need for meaning in life. Fandom is well suited to help meet those types of needs.
我经常这样做。我会问他们，谁是你最喜欢的球队？比方说，我正在和某个住在波士顿附近的人交谈。他们会说，嗯，我喜欢红袜队，我喜欢凯尔特人队，我喜欢爱国者队，我喜欢曼联。你会觉得，等等，什么？这些东西里有一个与众不同。这非常有趣，因为那支球队让他们感到与其他人不同。所以我想说，最直接的回答是，人们成为粉丝是因为它帮助他们满足了这些基本的心理需求。这并不是他们满足这些需求的唯一途径，但诸如归属感、对独特性的需求、对结构的需求以及对生活意义的需求等事物。粉丝文化非常适合帮助满足这些类型的需求。
So what's the research? How do you study fans and find out technically that they really are benefiting mentally from being fans? Yeah, we do it so many ways. Like so many minds of research in psychology over the years. You find laboratory methods and you also find field research. We've done it in my research program, both ways we will, you know, engage the, as they've been referred to before, the prey of the social psychology research or your lovely psychology introductory students. But I also really like going out into the field and going to sporting events and talking to them and surveying them. I have a research team that pretty much every year we will pick specific sporting events around the area and we'll go to. And we always get with these people
那么研究结果是什么呢？你如何研究粉丝，并在技术上发现他们确实从作为粉丝中获得了心理上的益处？是的，我们通过很多方法来做到这一点。就像多年来心理学中的许多研究思路一样。你会发现实验室方法，你也会找到实地研究。在我的研究项目中，我们以这两种方式做过，我们会，你知道的，接触，正如之前所提到的，社会心理学研究的“猎物”或者你可爱的心理学入门学生。但我其实也非常喜欢走出去，去到实地，去体育赛事现场与他们交谈并对他们进行调查。我有一个研究团队，几乎每年我们都会在当地挑选特定的体育赛事去参加。我们总是会在这些活动中与这些人...
before the games because I don't want to interrupt their entertainment value as well. But we'll sit down. We'll pass out questionnaires, talk to them. And I like doing that because it's in the moment for them. So if they're at the sporting event, sport is at that point in time saving to them. And I do think you get some some more authentic responses than if they're sitting in a classroom and, you know, stressed out about the test they're about to take in two hours. So we will use all types of methods. We'll go to major sporting events. We'll go to minor sporting events. We'll go to youth sporting events. Then we'll also, you know, just grab the random psychology student that's in a classroom. And does it matter to one's health, whether you're a fan of, you know, your kids' little league
比赛开始前进行接触，因为我也不想打扰他们的娱乐价值。但我们会坐下来。分发问卷，与他们交谈。我喜欢这样做，因为这对他们来说是当下发生的。因此，如果他们身处体育赛事现场，那么在那个时间点上，运动对他们来说就是拯救。而且我确实认为，与他们坐在教室里，对两个小时后即将参加的考试感到压力相比，你能得到一些更真实的反应。所以我们会使用各种类型的方法。我们会去大型体育赛事。我们会去小型体育赛事。我们会去青少年体育赛事。然后我们也会，你知道的，随手抓住教室里的一个随机心理学生。那么，成为你孩子的少儿联盟的粉丝，对个人的健康重要吗...
or a national team? Yeah, that's a great question. And what we find is it really does not. What is critical is the extent to which the person does identify with that team. A term that we will often throw out there in sports psych is team identification, which is simply the extent to which the fan feels some type of psychological connection to the team. How much is the team an extension of the fan? How central is that team and being a fan of that team to their own?
还是国家队的粉丝重要？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我们发现其实并没有什么区别。至关重要的是个人对该球队的认同程度。我们在运动心理学中经常抛出的一个术语是“团队认同”（team identification），这简而言之就是粉丝对球队产生某种心理连接的程度。这支球队在多大程度上是粉丝的延伸？这支球队以及成为该球队粉丝的核心程度如何...
self or social identity. And what we found is across multiple studies and multiple levels of competition from youth sports, college sports, high school sports, all the way up to, you know, major professional sports in the Olympics is that the more the fan is identified with a local team, the greater that that individual is likely to have a well-rounded sense of psychological health, lower levels of loneliness, lower levels of alienation, a higher sense of self-relivenous, higher sense of self-esteem, less social isolation. And a critical point is it's not necessarily the team identification itself that drives this finding. It's the fact that if you identify with a local team, that identification brings with it a group that you can then belong to. And by then
自我或社会认同。我们发现，在多项研究和从青少年体育、大学体育、高中体育一直到（你知道的）大型职业体育和奥运会的多个竞争级别中，粉丝对当地球队的认同度越高，该个人就越有可能拥有全面的心理健康感、较低的孤独感、较低的疏离感、更高的自我实现感、更高的自尊感以及更少的社会隔离。一个关键点是，驱动这一发现的未必是团队认同本身。而是这样一个事实：如果你认同了一支当地球队，这种认同就会带来一个你可以随之归属的群体。通过然后...
getting this sense of belonging, you're then going to get this sense that, well, you know what, I'm not alone in the world. And that's a great thing for our well-being. Again, to go back to Boston, if you're walking around a Boston mall here in the early spring with a Boston Red Sox cap, people are talking to you, right? You've got all of these friends there at the mall. You don't know where they work. You don't know what their name is. You don't know where they live.
获得这种归属感，你就会产生一种感觉，好吧，你知道吗，我在世界上并不孤单。这对我们的幸福感来说是一件好事。再次回到波士顿，如果你在初春时节戴着一顶波士顿红袜队的帽子走在波士顿的商场里，人们会跟你说话，对吧？你在商场里有所有这些朋友。你不知道他们在哪里工作。你不知道他们的名字。你不知道他们住在哪里。
But they're saying hi to you. It would be really hard to feel lonely at that point in time. The last point that I'll make is that we know that it's changing now, this sense of gaining psychological health from fandom. because of the digital age that we're in, you know, 15 years ago to follow a sport team and feel connected to others, you kind of had to live in that environment. You can watch a sporting event now
但他们在对你打招呼。在那个时间点上，要感到孤独真的很难。我要提出的最后一点是，我们知道这种通过粉丝文化获得心理健康的感觉现在正在发生改变。因为我们所处的数字时代，你知道的，15年前，要关注一支运动队并感到与他人有连接，你基本上得生活在那种环境中。你现在可以观看一场体育赛事...
from anywhere on the planet and plug in online and feel as though you're actually watching it with others. So we're being forced to change some of our thinking about how fan impacts well-being because, well, being a fan has changed over the last 15 and 20 years because of the social age.
从地球上的任何地方，并在线接入，感觉就像你真的在和别人一起观看一样。因此，由于社交时代的原因，过去15到20年粉丝身份发生了变化，这迫使我们改变对粉丝如何影响幸福感的一些思考方式。
What if your team is having a bad season? If you're a really passionate fan, can a loss or a bad season harm your mental health? I guess that would depend on how you would define harm your mental health. Most certainly it can make you cranky, upset, aggressive, hostile, violent, in a bad mood, surly. These are the things that would be words that would describe me over the years following both the Cubs and the Kansas City Royals. So I have a lot of expertise with following bad teams. I've kind of perfected it, as a matter of fact. The good news, I say, the bad news would be that, yes, certainly following sports teams,
如果你的球队正经历一个糟糕的赛季呢？如果你是一个真正充满热情的粉丝，一场失利或一个糟糕的赛季会损害你的心理健康吗？我想这取决于你如何定义“损害你的心理健康”。它当然可以让你变得暴躁、沮丧、具有攻击性、充满敌意、暴力、情绪糟糕、阴沉。这些年来一直关注小熊队和堪萨斯城皇家队，这些词就是用来形容我的。所以我对关注糟糕的球队有很多专业经验。事实上，我把它练得炉火纯青。好消息是，我说，坏消息是，是的，当然关注运动球队，
because it is central to the identity of highly identified fans, it is going to matter. If you were to take away the emotional response of being a sport fan, you would take away the point of being a sports fan, right? I mean, to be a fan is to be emotional. The elation from the win, the disappointment in the loss, and every potentially emotional range in between those two things. But if a fan feels disappointed at the loss, that's just a natural reaction. They care about these things.
因为它是高度认同的粉丝身份的核心，所以它会产生影响。如果你剥夺了作为体育迷的情感反应，你就剥夺了作为体育迷的意义，对吧？我的意思是，成为一个粉丝就是要充满情感。从胜利中获得的兴奋，在失利中的失望，以及这两者之间所有潜在的情感范围。但如果一个粉丝对失利感到失望，那只是一种自然的反应。他们关心这些事情。
And the problem is they can't do a whole lot about it, right? They put their heart and soul into following the team, and they're just this idle spectator going, well, I sure hope things go in my direction today. It's not exactly like, I'm the one shooting the free thrower. I'm the one swinging the bat. So they had this sort of sense of helplessness that can intensify the frustration. when they lose. But if that occurs, the beauty of it is that nobody, I think, has perfected coping strategies
问题是他们对此无能为力，对吧？他们倾注了全部心血去关注这支球队，而他们只是一个无所作为的旁观者，心想：“我真希望事情今天能朝对我有益的方向发展。”这可完全不像是我在罚球，也不是我在挥棒。因此，当他们输球时，他们会产生一种无助感，从而加剧挫败感。但如果这种情况发生了，它的美妙之处在于，我认为没有人能完美掌握应对策略...
quite like sports fans of perfected coping strategies. People often ask me, what's the craziest thing about sports fans? I really believe that the craziest thing about sports fans is that there actually are sports fans. This has to be the only domain, the only voluntary activity where half that people know, literally, that they're going to be upset when this thing that they consume voluntarily is over, right? They know that there's at least a 50-50 chance that when they're done, I'm going to be sad. I'm not going to want to go to work tomorrow on and on and on.
就像体育粉丝将应对策略完美掌握了一样。人们经常问我，体育迷最疯狂的事情是什么？我真的相信，体育迷最疯狂的事情是，居然真的存在体育迷。这一定是个唯一的领域，唯一的自愿活动，在这个领域里，有一半的人明知当他们自愿消费的这个东西结束时，他们会感到沮丧，对吧？他们知道至少有百分之五十的几率，当这一切结束时，我会很难过。我明天不想去上班，诸如此类。
And yet they still coming back. You would never do that if it was like delivery pizza. If like half the time they delivered your pizza late, cold and the wrong pizza, you would not keep going back. Sports fans, we just keep going back and we keep going back because we cope so well. We can look back on the glory years and it makes us feel better about the fact that our team is terrible now. Or we can look to the future and see the future as being even more exciting than it is now. I mean, after all, my team is the worst team in the NFL. Hey, that's good news because that means I have the best pick and the draft upcoming, right?
然而他们还是不断回头。如果你点外卖披萨是这样的话，你绝不会再去了。如果有一半时间他们送来的披萨既迟到、冰冷又送错了，你绝不会继续光顾。而体育迷，我们只是不断回头，我们不断回头是因为我们应对得太好了。我们可以回顾辉煌的岁月，这让我们对我们现在的球队糟糕透顶的事实感觉好一些。或者我们可以展望未来，把未来看得比现在更令人兴奋。毕竟，我的球队是 NFL 最烂的球队。嘿，这是个好消息，因为这意味着我能在接下来的选秀中拿到最好的顺位，对吧？
So we just have this way of convincing ourselves that it's all going to be okay. It's not okay now, but it's going to be okay in the future. And that's why fans, they just keep coming back. Again, I talk to lots of fans. and they so often tell me after losses, I'm never coming back. 100% of them have come back. That's great. What about the impact of betting on sports fans?
所以我们只是有这样一种方式来说服自己，这一切最终都会好起来的。现在情况不好，但未来会好起来的。这就是为什么粉丝们会不断回头。再次重申，我和很多粉丝交谈过。他们在失利后经常告诉我，我再也不回来了。其中百分之百的人都回来了。太棒了。那么下注对体育粉丝的影响呢？
Those who bet are invested in a different way. What's going on with them and when they win or lose what's happening psychologically? Yeah. You know, it's interesting. As I look back on the history of sport and then, of course, the history of fan that comes with it, it seems like every decade or two, There's a major change in how sport is played out that greatly impacts how fans consume and relate to teams and players in leagues and sports in general. You can think of when night games started, when sport got on TV, when free agency occurred and all of a sudden my favorite team is somehow now pitching for the rival team that I hate so much.
那些下注的人投入的方式不同。他们身上发生了什么？当他们赢或输时，心理上发生了什么？是的。你知道，这很有趣。当我回顾体育的历史，当然还有随之而来的粉丝历史时，似乎每隔十年或二十年，体育比赛的进行方式就会发生重大变化，这极大地影响了粉丝消费以及他们与球队、球员、联盟和整个体育运动的关系。你可以想想夜间比赛是什么时候开始的，体育运动是什么时候上电视的，自由球员制度是什么时候出现的，突然间我最喜欢的球队现在居然在为我如此痛恨的竞争对手球队投球。
I think that the new thing that we're looking at now is the fact that what was once an absolute giant no-no, which is betting on. on professional sports is now not just available, but embraced by the leagues who just a few short years ago thought that this was the worst thing that could possibly happen, that if individuals start to bet on sports, it's going to change how they're a sports fan. It's going to change how they follow teams. And they realize that, you know what, maybe it slightly does change how they follow sport and how they follow teams, but guess what? They do it more often because they have place to bet, and that's really good news for the sports leagues.
我认为我们现在看到的新事物是，曾经绝对是大忌的东西，即在职业体育上押注，现在不仅可以做到，而且受到了各个联盟的拥抱。而就在短短几年以前，他们还认为这是可能发生的糟糕的事情，如果个人开始在体育上押注，这将会改变他们作为体育迷的方式。这将会改变他们关注球队的方式。而他们意识到，你知道吗，也许它确实稍微改变了他们关注体育和球队的方式，但你猜怎么着？他们这样做的频率更高了，因为他们有了下注的地方，这对于体育联盟来说绝对是个好消息。
It's kind of surprising those that followed fans and studied for Solomon. It took the leagues that long to come around to realize that, hey, betting fans are, guess what, betting fans, so they're going to consume your product. We've actually conducted some pretty interesting studies that has looked at how we would expect betting to change fandom. them. We talk to fans, okay, if, you know, if and when they legalize sport wagering, you know, how will it change your perspective as a fan? And the bottom line from that research is it's really not going to do much, to be honest with you. It's not going to change a lot of individuals.
那些关注和研究粉丝的人会感到有点惊讶。联盟花了这么长时间才反应过来，意识到，嘿，押注的粉丝们，你猜怎么着，他们也是押注的粉丝，所以他们会消费你们的产品。我们实际上已经进行了一些非常有趣的研究，考察了我们预期押注会如何改变粉丝文化。我们与粉丝交谈，好吧，如果，你知道的，当他们将体育博彩合法化时，你知道，它将如何改变你作为粉丝的视角？那项研究的底线是，说实话，它真的不会产生太大影响。它不会改变很多个人。
The people that don't follow sport that could not care less about sport, they're not going to suddenly start following sport because you can bet. And the people that live for sport, they're not going to stop following sport because they can bet. They just might slightly consume some games that they wouldn't otherwise have watched, right? It would give them a reason to care about a game that their team is not playing or a rival team is not playing. So what our findings are, basically, it would slightly increase the interest for some fans. Fans that are lower on the scale of interest but still consider themselves a sport,
那些根本不关注体育、对体育漠不关心的人，不会因为你可以下注就突然开始关注体育。而那些为体育而活的人，也不会因为你可以下注就停止关注体育。他们可能只是会稍微多看一些原本不会看的比赛，对吧？这会给他们一个理由去关心一场他们的球队没有在踢、或者竞争对手球队没有在踢的比赛。所以我们的发现基本上是，它会稍微增加一些粉丝的兴趣。那些兴趣程度较低但仍然认为自己是体育迷的粉丝，
these are the ones that say, you know what, it might make me a little nervous or too anxious so I might not want to do it. So the moderate fans are like, I don't really need a reason to care in a way that's financially going to damage me. But for your typical, I love my team X fan, it just gives them one more reason to follow. What about when fans find out that somebody or even a whole team they revered was cheating, was doing something wrong, was doping like Lance Armstrong, for example. What happens to fans then?
这些人会说，你知道吗，这可能会让我有点紧张或太焦虑，所以我可能不想这么做。因此，温和的粉丝会觉得：我真的不需要一个会在经济上伤害我的理由去关心。但对于你那种典型的“我爱死我的球队X”的粉丝来说，这只是给了他们又一个关注的理由。当粉丝们发现他们崇拜的某个人甚至整支球队都在作弊、在做坏事、比如像兰斯·阿姆斯特朗那样使用兴奋剂时，会发生什么？那时粉丝们会怎么样？
Yeah, it really depends on their level of identification. Again, their level of psychological connection to the team. they're low in identification or moderate. So, you know, maybe it's a team that they sort of associate with or, you know, maybe they sort of follow their progress over the course of a year. But certainly it would not be something that they would, you know, highly self-identify as a fan of that team. For these individuals, they tend to, you know, put down the team of the player and it's going to decrease their likelihood of wanting to be associated with that team.
是的，这真的取决于他们的认同水平。再说一次，他们对球队的心理连接程度。如果他们的认同度低或中等。所以，你知道，也许是一支他们某种程度上有关联的球队，或者，你知道，也许他们某种程度上会关注他们一年来的进展。但这肯定不是那种他们会高度自我认同为该球队粉丝的事情。对于这些人来说，他们往往会，你知道的，贬低该球队或球员，并且这会降低他们想要与该球队产生关联的可能性。
The term that we use in social psychology is cutting off reflected failure. they will cut off their association, at least psychologically and publicly with that team. You know, we really, you often hear people say, we're known by the company we keep. And I always tell my students that that's not the point. The point isn't that we're known by the company we keep. The point is that we know that we are known by the company we keep. We realize that fact. And so that knowledge changes our behavior and nobody wants to be associated with someone
我们在社会心理学中使用的术语是“切断反射性失败”（cutting off reflected failure）。他们会切断与该球队的关联，至少在心理上和公开上是这样的。你知道，我们真的，你经常听到人们说，“物以类聚，人以群分”（我们通过我们交往的公司来了解自己）。我总是告诉我的学生，重点不是这个。重点不是我们通过交往的公司来了解自己。重点在于我们知道别人是通过我们交往的公司来了解我们的。我们意识到了这个事实。因此，这种认识改变了我们的行为，没有人愿意与某个人扯上关系...
that has done something negative or illegal or that is like, threatened the quality of this identity. Not nobody, actually, because those that are highly identified, you just have to wonder, you know, studying this for four decades, what do players and teams have to do to finally convince somebody that they are not worthy of their love? You know, it's like, I mean, steroids and DUIs and on and on and on, and there's still fan bases that hold on to those individuals. and once again, they do so because they have perfected coping.
做过负面或非法事情的人，或者像威胁到这种身份质量的人。并非没有人，实际上，对于那些高度认同的人，你只需要想一想，你知道的，研究了四十年，球员和球队到底要做什么才能终究说服某个人他们不值得他们的爱？你知道的，这就像是，我的意思是，类固醇、酒驾等等等等，仍然有粉丝群体死死抓住那些人不放。
They've figured out a way to externalize the individual's transgression. Well, you know, they're under a lot of pressure. They're under a lot of stress or, well, everybody does it. They actually weren't guilty. There was an Olympian a few years ago, several years ago now that was actually caught doping, performance enhancing drugs. and huge fans of this sprinter. One of the more common explanations they had
而且，他们再次这样做是因为他们已经把应对机制磨练得炉火纯青了。他们想出了一种将个人的越轨行为外在化的方法。好吧，你知道的，他们承受着很大的压力。他们承受着巨大的压力，或者，好吧，每个人都这么干。他们其实是无辜的。几年前，现在是好几年前了，有一位奥运选手实际上被抓到使用兴奋剂，也就是提高成绩的药物。这是他们最常见的解释之一...
was that the rival runners, sprinters, had actually switched out his water bottle and put out a water bottle that had the performance-enhancing drugs in it. And they weren't just like making this up. They were literally convinced, right? So the ability of sports fans to find a way to make it all fit
就是竞争对手的跑步者、短跑运动员实际上调换了他的水瓶，放了一个含有兴奋剂的水瓶。他们可不仅仅是凭空捏造。他们简直是深信不疑，对吧？因此，体育粉丝找到一种方法让这一切合情合理、
and be okay is what allows them to, to continue to support these individuals. Now, again, they're not completely foolish, and they understand that, you know, when somebody does something, they'll say they shouldn't have done that. They really shouldn't have done that. That was a horrible thing to do.
没有问题的能力，才是让他们能够继续支持这些个人的原因。现在，话说回来，他们并不是完全愚蠢的，他们也明白，你知道的，当某人做了某事时，他们会说他们不该那样做。他们真的不该那样做。那是一件糟糕透顶的事情。
Then they follow that up with, but I'm a forgiving soul, and so it's all okay with me. Now, why do some people root for underdogs and other people always want to be on the bandwagon with the winning team? Yeah, it's so interesting. interesting how when you look at people, they either want to pick the surefire winner or the gross underdog. It's like they don't want to pick the team that's 50-50. And the reason is both of those two,
然后他们接着说，但我是一个宽容的人，所以这一切对我来说都没问题。现在，为什么有些人支持弱势的一方，而另一些人总是想跟风支持赢球的球队呢？是的，这太有趣了。当你观察人们时，他们要么想挑选十拿九稳的赢家，要么挑选绝对的弱者。就好像他们不想挑选胜率为五成对五成的球队一样。原因在于这两者，
picking the high favorite or the serious underdog, the long shot, both of those two are so psychologically safe. If you pick a team that is slated to be like a 95% likelihood to win, that's a safe. That's a safe selection. So is picking the team that's a 5% likelihood to win because should that team lose, and it looks like they're going to, you can very easily say, hey, you know, they had no chance. Now, the advantage is if you pick the underdog and they lose, you can say that, right? You can say, well, let's be honest. They never really had a chance. Ah, but if they win, isn't that victory that much sweeter? Isn't that victory that much better because it's unexpected? So I always say that that's where rooting for the underdog,
选择超级大热门还是绝对的弱旅、冷门，这两者在心理上都是极其安全的。如果你选择一支被认为有 95% 胜率的球队，那是一个安全的。那是一个安全的抉择。选择一支只有 5% 胜率的球队同样如此，因为万一这支球队输了（而看起来他们也确实会输），你可以非常轻松地说：“嘿，你知道的，他们本来就毫无机会。”现在，好处是如果你选择了弱旅而他们输了，你可以这么说，对吧？你可以说：“嗯，说实话。他们从来就没什么机会。”啊，但如果他们赢了呢？那场胜利不是更甜美吗？那场胜利不是因为出乎意料而变得更好吗？所以我总是说，这就是支持弱势一方的精髓所在，
relative to a favored team, rooting to the underdog, that's a win-win. If they lose, hey, it's okay. We're the lovable losers. We're supposed to. If we win, oh my gosh, how in the world do we pull that off? One of the best victories ever. It's amazing how people like safe choices. Underdogs are safe choices.
相对于被看好的球队，支持弱势的一方，那是稳赚不赔的。如果他们输了，嘿，没关系。我们是惹人怜爱的失败者。我们本该如此。如果我们赢了，哦天哪，我们到底是怎么做到的？这是有史以来最好的胜利之一。人们喜欢安全的抉择，这真是太神奇了。弱势群体就是安全的抉择。
What about the effect of fans on teams? themselves, I mentioned in the intro, the home field advantage. Is it a real thing? Absolutely. So there's a few ways that research over the years, over the decades, mostly from social psychology, has examined, do crowds matter, right? I mean, certainly they matter to the bottom line and the pocketbooks of the people that own the teams and leagues, but do they actually matter on the field in terms of performance? And there's a couple of ways that they do. Certainly, social facilitation, the fact that being around others can kind of get people to rise to the occasion or maybe choke under pressure that can have a play in this. But I think that from a sports psych
那么粉丝对球队本身的影响呢？我在引言中提到了主场优势。这是一个真实存在的现象吗？绝对是。因此，多年来、几十年来的研究（主要来自社会心理学）通过几种方式探讨了人群是否重要，对吧？我的意思是，它们对拥有球队和联盟的人的底线和钱包肯定很重要，但它们在场上的表现上真的重要吗？确实有几种方式证明它们很重要。当然，社会助长作用，即身处他人之中可以促使人们迎接挑战，或者在压力下发挥失常，这在其中起到了作用。但我认为从体育心理学的角度来看，
perspective, most individuals do want to talk about and think about, is there this home field advantage? It is one of the most well-replicated and substantiated findings in the realm of sport psychology, that home teams, they just do win more. It doesn't matter the level of competition. It doesn't matter the type of sport. Home teams are going to win more. Typically, about 60 to 40, home teams will have an advantage. And they have over the decades put forth several potential explanations for this. One popular one, a few decades back was travel and fatigue. Well, you know, traveling several hours, you know, by. plane is probably going to wear them down. I mean, have you looked at the planes these people travel
角度而言，大多数人都想讨论和思考的是：真的存在这种主场优势吗？这是体育心理学领域中被重复次数最多、最得到实证支持的发现之一，即主场球队确实赢得更多。比赛级别并不重要。运动类型并不重要。主场球队总是赢得更多。通常情况下，主场球队会占据大约 60% 对 40% 的优势。几十年来，他们针对这一点提出了几种可能的解释。几十年前一个流行的解释是旅行和疲劳。嗯，你知道的，坐几个小时的飞机旅行，
on? They're nicer than my house. I mean, I don't know. You know, they probably get to the hotel and look around and go, this five-star hotel is a dump compared to the airplane that we were just in. And so all these other sort of potential explanations, they might matter a little bit. But what research in the last maybe 10 years has found is that what fans are doing is they're influencing the outcomes of the calls of the officials, that the officials are the ones far more than the players that are being influenced by the fans. A great example of this, there's lots of research. A great example of this is some researchers found that there's actually a home field advantage in Olympics. Really? But they don't find it for objective sports like the 100 meter dash. They find it
坐飞机可能会把他们累垮。我的意思是，你看过这些人旅行时坐的飞机吗？它们比我的房子还要好。我的意思是，我不知道。你知道的，他们大概到了酒店环顾四周，然后说：“跟我们刚刚坐的飞机相比，这家五星级酒店简直是个垃圾堆。”所以所有这些其他潜在的解释，可能有一点点关系。但过去大概 10 年的研究发现，粉丝们正在做的是，他们正在影响裁判的判罚结果，裁判比球员更容易受到粉丝的影响。这方面的一个绝佳例子，有很多研究。这方面的一个绝佳例子是，一些研究人员发现奥运会中实际上也存在主场优势。真的吗？但他们没有在 100 米短跑等客观运动中发现这一点。他们在...
for subjective sports like gymnastics and diving, where the judges have such a huge impact on the outcome. That's where they find the home foot advantage, where the officials really do have the biggest say. In football games, some football stadiums will have a track, a running track, like the track meet track around the football stadiums. Others don't have that. You get a higher home field advantage when that track is not there because the fans are that much closer to the officials and they have that much more of an influence on the officials. So what we know is, yes, the homeful advantage is alive and well and an honest thing. And it looks like from the current state of the research that the big impact is not on the players themselves as a message it's on, the fans having influence on the decisions that the umpires and the referees are making.
体操和跳水等主观运动中发现了这一点，裁判对比赛结果有着巨大的影响。这就是他们发现主场优势的地方，裁判在那里确实拥有最大发言权。在足球比赛中，一些足球场会有一条跑道，就像田径运动会那样的跑道环绕着足球场。另一些则没有。当没有那条跑道时，你会获得更高的主场优势，因为粉丝离裁判更近，他们对裁判的影响力也更大。所以我们知道，主场优势确实存在且是一个真实的事情。从目前的最新研究状态来看，巨大的影响不在于球员本身，而是粉丝对裁判和裁判员做出的决定产生了影响。
Are there common traits among certain types of fans? For instance, do some people become fans because they have low self-esteem and they need some external validation? or do people with, say, violent tendencies revere boxing and mixed martial arts? We've been looking for the, like, the recipe for a sports fan for a long time in sports psychology. And I'm sad to say we have not yet found it. Every time we think we might have found one, somebody else comes along as a sports fan, and they're completely different. If you go to a stadium that has as few as 150, 200 people,
某些类型的粉丝之间是否存在共同的特征？例如，有些人成为粉丝是因为他们自尊心低，需要一些外部认可吗？或者具有暴力倾向的人会崇拜拳击和综合格斗吗？在体育心理学中，我们寻找体育迷的“秘方”已经很久了。我很遗憾地宣布，我们还没有找到它。每当我们以为自己可能找到了一个时，就会出现另一个完全不同的体育迷。如果你去到一个只有 150、200 人的体育场，
in that stadium watching a game, you're going to find every single different personality trait possible among those 150 and 200 people. Now, does that mean that we haven't found certain characteristics of sports fans in research? I mean, we have, right? So, for example, sports fans tend to slide slightly towards an extroverted crowd. That makes sense because, you know, most sports fans, they will consume in a public scenario. But when you look at the at how much variance is accounted for, right? How powerful these effects are. It's just minuscule, right? And so what we really say now is that sure, maybe individuals who tend towards a preference for stylistic things in life would lean towards, I don't know, diving, gymnastics, figure skating,
在这座体育场里观看比赛，在这 150 到 200 人中，你会发现每一种可能的人格特质。现在，这是否意味着我们在研究中没有发现体育迷的某些特征？我的意思是，我们发现了，对吧？所以，例如，体育迷往往略微倾向于外向的人群。这合情合理，因为，你知道的，大多数体育迷，他们会在公开的场景下进行消费。但当你看看差异占了多少比例，对吧？这些影响有多强大。它实在是微不足道，对吧？所以我们现在真正要说的是，当然，也许那些偏爱生活中具有风格化事物的人会倾向于——我不知道——跳水、体操、花样滑冰，
that maybe that's there, but it's such a small effect that you're way better off. saying every kind of person seems to like every kind of sport out there. We did some research a few years ago where we thought, you know what, I bet there should be a scenario where fans that are, they're really into it because of the family nature of sport that they see sport as an opportunity to spend time with their kids and their spouses. We thought those people, they really shouldn't like violent sports, right? That doesn't seem like it should fit. Nope, not at all.
也许这确实存在，但它的影响如此之小，以至于你不如直接说：各种各样的人似乎都喜欢那里的各种各样的体育运动。几年前我们做过一项研究，当时我们想，你知道吗，我打赌应该存在这样一种情况：粉丝们之所以真正投入其中，是因为体育的家庭性质，他们将体育视为与孩子和配偶共度时光的机会。我们认为那些人真的不应该喜欢暴力运动，对吧？这似乎说不通。不，一点也不。
We absolutely found that they don't care at all, that they're going to take their kids to the track meet and they're going to take their kids to the bowling alley and they're going to take them to the professional wrestling match. It literally did not matter to these people. We also thought that, well, maybe instead they would like stylistic sports, you know, and nope, didn't matter. It just every kind of person that you can imagine seems like every different kind of sport that is out there. And when you factor in how many millions and millions and millions of fans there are in the world, that kind of starts to make some sense. When does fandom cross the line into something unhealthy, I'm assuming that it sometimes does? Any time you have individuals that can get as wrapped up into something as some fans can get into sport, you're going to have individuals who cross the line. I always refer to this as the darker side of sport fandom.
我们绝对发现他们根本不在乎，他们会带孩子去田径运动会，带孩子去保龄球馆，带孩子去职业摔角比赛。这对这些人来说简直毫无影响。我们还认为，也许他们会转而喜欢风格化的运动，你知道的，不，完全没关系。你能量出的每一种人，似乎都喜欢那里每一种不同的运动。当你把世界上数以百万计的粉丝考虑在内时，这其实就开始说得通了。粉丝文化在什么时候会越界变成不健康的东西？我假设有时确实会这样。任何时候，当有些人能够像某些粉丝痴迷于体育那样全身心投入某件事时，你就会遇到越界的人。我总是把这称为体育粉丝文化的黑暗面。
I think that it's critical that we talk about this. I think that it's critical that we don't only talk about this. I think that that was one of the, I mean, it was a criticism of psychology, right? I mean, you know, for so long, we just didn't want to really talk about the good sides of humanity. Positive psychology comes along, you know, three, four decades ago and, you know, kind of lets us know, hey, it's okay to talk about high self-esteem as well as low self-esteem. that's a good thing. It's a good thing to talk about what sport fandom does positively, but we also have to be honest and admit that, you know, there are times when sports fans do things
我认为我们讨论这一点至关重要。我认为我们不能仅仅讨论这一点，这至关重要。我认为那是心理学受到的批评之一，对吧？我的意思是，长久以来，我们就是不想真正谈论人性的美好面。积极心理学在三、四十年出现，你知道的，让我们知道，嘿，谈论高自尊以及低自尊是没问题的。那是件好事。谈论体育粉丝文化带来的积极影响是件好事，但我们也必须诚实地承认，你知道的，有时体育迷做的事情...
that cross the line. I think certainly sport fan aggression is the obvious thing at the top of this list, that there are fans that, I mean, they do things that they should not do. I mean, they hurl things at players. They say things at players and they get in fights with fans. And it is not a pretty sight when it occurs. It is rare. So one of the things, in addition to the fact that sports fandom can have this facilitating effect for some individuals on aggression where they get too wrapped up in the moment at the sporting event, we can also see some of the darker side in terms of their interpersonal relationships and their lack of care about their job, that we actually have individuals out there that they'll admit that they will consume sport over 100 hours a week. And if you consume something 100 hours a week, that doesn't give a whole lot of time for, I mean, a loved one, your kids, a job, sleep, food. It doesn't give a whole lot of time for anything. And so I think that, again, we have to admit that these things are there.
确实越界了。我认为体育迷的攻击性肯定是这份清单榜首显而易见的事，有些粉丝，我的意思是，他们做了一些他们不该做的事。我的意思是，他们向球员投掷物品。他们对球员口出恶言，还跟其他粉丝打架。当这种情况发生时，画面真是不忍直视。这很罕见。因此，除了体育粉丝文化会对某些个人的攻击性产生这种促进作用，使他们在体育赛事现场过于投入这一事实之外，我们还可以在他们的人际关系以及他们对工作的漠不关心方面看到一些黑暗面，我们实际上有一些人会承认，他们每周花在消费体育上的时间超过 100 小时。如果你每周花 100 小时消费某样东西，那就没有多少时间留给，我的意思是，你的爱人、你的孩子、工作、睡觉、吃饭。这几乎没留出多少时间给任何其他事情。所以我想，再次强调，我们必须承认这些事情是真实存在的。
Very small percentage. Most individuals, they will say that sport fan is a positive influence on their relationship. About two or three percent will say it probably has some type of detrimental effect. But again, if you're going to say that one fight in a crowd is too many, I'm going to say that 2% of individuals having their lives negatively impacted by fandom is 2% too many. It shouldn't have that negative effect. And so we need to talk about the darker side as well. We need to be honest with ourselves and say, okay, can we do things that lower these numbers, that move the needle? because if 2% have a negative impact for fandom on their interpersonal relationships,
极小的比例。大多数人会说体育粉丝对他们的关系产生了积极的影响。大约百分之二到三的人会说它可能具有某种有害的影响。但话说回来，如果你要说人群中的一次打架就太多了，我会说百分之二的人的生活受到粉丝文化的负面影响，这就已经多出百分之二了。它不应该产生那种负面影响。因此，我们也需要讨论黑暗的一面。我们需要对 ourselves 诚实，并说，好吧，我们能否做些事情来降低这些数字，推动指标发生变化？因为如果百分之二的人的人际关系因为粉丝文化而受到了负面影响，
that means there's 2% of relationship partners, right? 2% of families. If you have one fight in the stands, okay, fine, that's two people, maybe three people, four people, but that's dozens of people around that individual who had their positive experience seriously interrupted. And they can feel threatened by this. And we know that one incidents like this is enough to make some individuals shy away from coming back. It puts a bad taste in their mouth.
这意味着有 2% 的恋爱伴侣，对吧？2% 的家庭。如果你在看台上吵了一架，好吧，那也就是两个人，也许三个人、四个人，但那个有负面体验的个人周围有几十个人，他们的积极体验受到了严重干扰。他们可能会因此感到威胁。我们知道，像这样的一起事件就足以让一些人怯于再次光临。这给他们留下了糟糕的印象。
And so just because it's, you know, vastly in the minority, that doesn't mean it isn't worthy of our attention and isn't potentially impacting more people in total than you might think. Is this kind of aggression among fans on the increase? Boy, wouldn't we love to know that? So I've been giving these interviews for the better part of three and a half decades. That is for certain, the most common question that I get. And it is awful to answer the most common question that you get for one third of a century by saying, we don't know. I wish I had an answer, but I just do not want to lie and not reflect the research.
因此，仅仅因为它在绝大多数情况下只是极少数，并不意味着它不值得我们关注，也不意味着它对整体潜在影响的人数比你想象的要少。粉丝之间的这种攻击性在增加吗？天哪，我们多想知道答案啊！所以，我接受这些采访已经有三十五年多的时间了。毫无疑问，这是我被问到最多的问题。用“我们不知道”来回答一个延续了三分之一个世纪的最常见问题，这种感觉太糟糕了。我希望我能有一个答案，但我绝对不想撒谎，不想背离研究结果。
And in this case, what research? How would we ever know? Right. So when we define aggression among fans, it counts if you're yelling obscenities, as it should. It counts if you're yelling obscenities. There's nobody in the stands with a clicker, right? Counting obscenies. Probably there should be, right?
在这种情况下，又是什么研究？我们怎么可能知道呢？对吧。因此，当我们定义粉丝之间的攻击性时，如果你在狂吼脏话，那就算数，理应如此。如果你在狂吼脏话，这就算数。看台上可没有人拿着计数器在数脏话，对吧？也许应该有人去数，对吧？
Maybe we don't want to know those numbers. But I can say this. There are certainly a lot of theoretical perspectives out there that would suggest that, yes, sport fan aggression is on the rise. We might not have absolute concrete numbers. But we know things that would suggest that it should be. For example, we know that team identification can play a role in aggression. And we know that people are now more likely to identify with sports teams than there were maybe 20, 40, 60 years ago.
也许我们并不想知道这些数字。但我可以这么说。肯定有很多理论观点表明，是的，体育粉丝的攻击性正在上升。我们可能没有绝对具体的数字。但我们知道一些迹象表明它应该在上升。例如，我们知道团队认同感会在攻击性中起到一定作用。而且我们知道，与20、40、60年前相比，现在的人们更有可能认同体育团队。
Because other social institutions with which they used to identify work, extended family living close to home, attending religious institutions, these things can be on the decline. Something has to take the place of that, right? where we're not going to stop being, you know, social creatures. If fandom is chosen as the option to take the place of that, all of a sudden you care more about fandom. All of a sudden, you're more likely to get upset if they lose. Society, we're not as nice as we used to be. You know, empathy levels are going down,
因为他们曾经认同的其他社会机构正在衰落，比如居住在附近的大家庭、参加宗教活动，这些事情可能都在走下坡路。总得有东西来取代它，对吧？我们不会停止成为社会动物的。如果粉丝文化被选为替代品，突然之间，你就会更关心粉丝文化。突然之间，如果他们输了，你也就更容易沮丧。社会上，我们不像以前那么友好了。你知道，同理心水平在下降，
civility levels going down. People have traced this for many decades. If society has less civility, why would we expect there to be anything different among the fans in stadiums, right? So I can't say, yes, in 2019, the number was this. And in 2014, it was this. But I can tell you, theories matter. And we know that there are several theories that would suggest that, yeah, it's on the rise.
文明水平在下降。人们追踪了这一现象几十年。如果社会的文明程度降低了，为什么我们还期望体育场里的粉丝会有所不同呢？所以我不能说，是的，在2019年这个数字是多少，而在2014年是多少。但我可以告诉你，理论很重要。我们知道有几个理论表明，是的，它在上升。
And then you can also just say, go to a sporting event, trying to remember what it was like, you know, 25, 45, 55 years ago. It doesn't feel the same. Right. Right. 55 years ago, they didn't have family sections. They have to have family sections. now because they have to quarantine the people who don't want to be exposed to all the rowdy and dysfunctional fans.
然后你也可以直接去观看一场体育赛事，试着回想一下它在 25、45、55 年前是什么样的。感觉完全不一样了。对的，对的。55 年前，他们没有家庭专区。现在他们必须设立家庭专区，因为他们必须把那些不想接触所有粗鲁和失控粉丝的人隔离起来。
That should tell you that, yeah, maybe something not so pleasant is going on. Sure, sure. And the men were wearing suits and the women were wearing dresses. Exactly. Different world. Yeah. Now, speaking of age, I've read some reporting that younger people are less likely to be sports fans now than older generations. There was a recent article in USA Today that was called Gen Z doesn't care about.
这应该能说明，是的，可能有些不太愉快的事情正在发生。确实，确实。而且当时男士们穿着西装，女士们穿着裙子。完全没错。完全是另一个世界。是的。说到年龄，我读到一些报道称，与年长的一代相比，现在的年轻人不太可能是体育迷。《今日美国》最近有一篇文章叫做“Z世代根本不在乎体育”。
sports. Does that track with your experience and research? And if it does, what do you think is causing this? There's no doubt that that's true. As a matter of fact, one of the recent conversations I had with some of the administration in our university's athletic department was that, you know, we draw pretty well for our men's basketball team. Murray State historically has had a pretty good men's basketball team. And, you know, we'll get, you know, five, six, seven thousand fans for a typical game, not bad for a mid-major university. And I told our athletic director said, if I are you, I'd be nervous because when you look around, you know, they're all in their 40s and 50s and 60s.
这符合你的经历和研究吗？如果符合，你认为是什么原因造成的？毫无疑问，这是真的。事实上，我最近和我们大学田径部门的一些管理人员交谈时，他们提到，我们在男子篮球队上吸引了相当多的观众。莫州大历来都有一支相当不错的男子篮球队。在一场典型的比赛中，我们会吸引五千、六千、七千名粉丝，对于一所中型大学来说这已经很不错了。我告诉我们的体育总监说，如果我是你，我会感到紧张，因为环顾四周，你会发现他们都在40多岁、50多岁和60多岁。
You don't see very, very, very few in their 20s at these sporting events. And certainly, you know, not in their teens. There are so many things that individuals that are 15, 20, 25, that they had, an opportunity to do and get exposed to when they were growing up that older generations did not, right? There are just more entertainment options that are out there. When I grew up, you had ABC, CBS, NBC, and pretty much that was it. On a good day, maybe PBS would come in, but that was about it.
你在这些体育赛事中几乎看不到20多岁的人，而且当然也没有十几岁的年轻人。15岁、20岁、25岁的年轻人，他们在成长过程中有机会去做、去接触的事情，比老一辈人要多得多，对吧？外面有太多的娱乐选择了。我长大的时候，只有ABC、CBS、NBC，基本上就是这些。运气好的话，可能会收到PBS，但也仅此而已。
And so now, how many different options just on TV and streaming and on and on, there's such a competition for the entertainment time for the younger generations that we didn't have. So less likely to be socialized into sport fandom because they're more likely to be doing other things, right? There's no doubt that this is true. Sport fandom is going to be very interesting in about 30 years when the people that buy tickets are no longer around to buy the tickets. I doubt I'll be here to see that.
所以现在，单单在电视、流媒体上就有多少不同的选择，等等，年轻一代对娱乐时间的争夺是以前没有的。因此，他们不太可能被社会化为体育迷，因为他们更有可能去做其他事情，对吧？毫无疑问，这是真的。大约30年后，当买票的人不再存在时，体育粉丝文化将会变得非常有趣。我怀疑我能不能活到那个时候看到这一幕。
If I am, I'm really curiously how that plays out. out because it's just fandom is aging out. Phantom is aging out. And I'm not saying that there aren't young individuals who are fans. There are. But just look at a stadium. I mean, it's an older crowd relative to what it used to be. And younger individuals, they have more opportunities.
如果我能看到，我真的很好奇事情会如何发展，因为粉丝群体正在逐渐老龄化。粉丝群体正在逐渐老龄化。我并不是说没有年轻的粉丝。有的。但只要看看体育场就知道了。我的意思是，相对于过去，这是一个更年长的群体。而年轻人有更多的机会。
They have more things to do. And so they're less likely to care about any one thing. So is this trend having an impact on your course enrollment? It does not. thankfully because there's always enough fans that are out there. Interestingly enough, I have about 20% of my sport fan psychology class that are absolutely not sports fans, that they detest sport. They've never followed it, and they don't understand it. And so they take the class to try and figure out what in the world is going on with all these people that are putting all this time and money into these activities.
他们有更多的事情要做，因此他们不太可能关心任何单一的事物。那么，这种趋势对你的课程注册人数有影响吗？谢天谢地，没有影响，因为总有足够多的粉丝存在。有趣的是，我的体育粉丝心理学课上大约有20%的学生绝对不是体育迷，他们甚至厌恶体育。他们从未关注过，也无法理解。所以他们上这门课是为了弄清楚，到底是怎么回事，为什么这些人会把这么多的时间和金钱投入到这些活动中。
And it's funny because they'll be apologetic about taking the class. And I tell him, no, I can't have enough of you people in this class because you give the counterbalance to class discussions, right? If it's just all a bunch of sports fans, the class discussion becomes preaching to the choir. The fact that I have three or four or five non-fans in there, it sort of serves as a check and a balance to the other individuals. And it really makes them do some type of, you know, self-awareness. of, yeah, why do I do so much of this? Apparently not everybody does, and it gets for much better conversations. So in the past few years, a lot of athletes have become more open about their mental health struggles. Do you think that this trend is changing the way that fans relate to athletes
有趣的是，他们选这门课时会感到有些抱歉。我告诉他们，不，这门课上绝对不能没有你们这样的人，因为你们为课堂讨论提供了对立面，对吧？如果全是一群体育迷，课堂讨论就会变成对信徒的说教。班上有三四个非粉丝的存在，这正好起到了对其他人的制衡作用。这确实促使他们进行某种自我觉察，思考：“是的，为什么我要做这么多这种事？显然不是每个人都这样。”这使得对话变得好得多。所以在过去的几年里，很多运动员对他们的心理健康挣扎变得更加开放。你认为这种趋势正在改变粉丝与运动员建立联系的方式吗？
and the way that they think about sports in general? You know, as a social scientist, I certainly hope so. I think that sports fans, you know, they're certainly slow to come around. I mean, let's just be honest, right? I mean, you change your team's logo, just the logo. And for like 20 years, they can't get over what a distrustful and awful scenario that was, right?
以及他们对体育整体的看法？你知道，作为一个社会学家，我当然希望如此。我认为体育粉丝的接受速度肯定很慢。让我们诚实一点，好吗？我的意思是，你更改了球队的标志，仅仅是标志。在长达20年的时间里，他们都无法释怀那是多么令人不信任和糟糕的场景，对吧？
That's just the picture of some creature. And for years, we know that athletes were taught to, you know, suck it up, don't cry, this and that. I hope that athletes by coming out are changing how fans view athletes and that they're not animals, that they're not robots, that they're actually humans, that they have feelings, that they are fallible, and that what they're doing, their performance is in the public eye. Everybody gets to see when they have a bad day. And I think that a lot of fans would be really upset if everybody, and by everybody, and by
那只是一些某种生物的图片。多年来，我们知道运动员被教导要“咬牙坚持”、“不要哭泣”、诸如此类的话。我希望运动员通过公开表达正在改变粉丝看待运动员的方式，让他们明白运动员不是动物，不是机器人，他们实际上是有人类情感的，他们会犯错，而且他们的所作所为、他们的表现都暴露在公众眼皮底下。每个人都能看到他们状态不佳的时候。我想，如果每个人——我说的每个人是指字面上的数百万人——都能看到你在工作中搞砸了的时候，很多粉丝会真的感到沮丧。
everybody, I mean, literally millions of people get to see when you messed up at work. I think that that might change their perspective. My hope is that individuals see the humanity in athletics and that we start to give these people a little bit of slack that, you know what, it's okay for them to be human too. I mean, it should be. They are human. Yeah. Like Simone Biles getting the twisties.
我认为这可能会改变他们的看法。我的希望是人们能在体育运动中看到人性，并开始对这些人多包容一点，你知道吗，允许他们也做回普通人。我的意思是，本来就该如此。他们本来就是人。是的。就像拜尔斯遭遇“空中转体失控”一样。
Exactly. And you know what? As it comes out more and fans get more used to it, more athletes will then feel empowered to come out. And it will seem less abnormal. And then that's that snowball that you hope you see over the next eight, 10, 12 years. So what's next for you? What else are you looking at? What are the big questions?
完全正确。你知道吗？随着这种情况越来越多地被公开，粉丝们也越来越习惯，更多的运动员就会感到有底气站出来。这看起来就不会那么不正常了。然后这就形成了你希望在未来 8、10、12 年里看到的滚雪球效应。那么你接下来要做什么？你还在关注什么？有哪些重大问题？
So what we've been looking at now actually is fans' beliefs about. how they think they can influence the outcomes of sporting events. We know that they sort of can by, you know, maybe potentially have an impact on the players, but definitely having an impact on officials. Well, we've been asking them, what do you do to try and influence the outcome? So to what extent do you have superstitions, prayer, yell encouragement, yell derogatory comments towards the officials and the other team? And what we found was so interesting in the first study that's under review.
所以我们现在实际在研究的是粉丝对于自己如何能够影响体育赛事结果的信念。我们知道他们某种程度上确实可以做到，比如可能对球员产生潜在影响，但绝对能对裁判产生影响。我们一直在问他们，你们做了什么来试图影响结果？因此，在多大程度上你们会有迷信、祈祷、大声鼓励、对裁判和对方球队大喊贬损性的言论？我们在正在接受评审的第一项研究中发现了一个非常有趣的结果：
view at a journal now is that all of the different methods that they use are positively correlated. So the more they use one method, the more they use another. That to me is absolutely hysterical because it means that the more someone is likely to cuss out an official to help the team win is also more likely to pray to help the team win. And somewhere, that to me is just so wonderfully funny. I can't get it, get past it. The stay that we're starting now that we'll begin this fall is, now that we know that fans engage in these acts to try and influence, we're now asking them, which ones do you think work best, right? We know what they do. Now, we'd like to know, okay, so, you know, pitchers have their go-to pitch, point guards have their go-to move.
目前正在一家期刊评审中，结果显示他们使用的所有不同方法之间都呈正相关。也就是说，他们使用某种方法的频率越高，使用另一种方法的频率也越高。这对我来说绝对滑稽透顶，因为这意味着一个人越倾向于大骂裁判来帮助球队取胜，他也越倾向于通过祈祷来帮助球队取胜。在某些层面上，这对我来说实在太好笑了。我简直无法释怀。我们今年秋天将要开始的新研究是，既然我们知道粉丝会为了尝试影响结果而做出这些举动，我们现在要问他们，你们认为哪种方法最管用，对吧？我们知道他们的行为。现在，我们想知道，好吧，投手有他们的绝招，控卫有他们的绝招。
We want to know what the fans go-to active influence is when it's really close, right? When it's really close, do you cuss or do you pray? Or do you rub your lucky rabbit's foot? That's what we're after now. That's a great question. Well, Dr. Juan, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been a lot of fun. Thank you. Absolutely been my pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们想知道当比分非常接近时，粉丝们的绝招是什么，对吧？当比分非常接近时，你是大骂还是祈祷？还是去摸摸你的幸运兔脚？这就是我们现在正在寻找的答案。这是一个极好的问题。好的，万博士，非常感谢你今天加入我们的节目。这真的非常有趣。谢谢你。这绝对是我的荣幸。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》之前的节目，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方收听。
And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email, us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyian. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢我们节目，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发邮件给我们，邮箱是 SpeakingofPsychology@APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪安（Chris Kondyian）。感谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。